[Action introductory
music playing]
[Suspenseful music plays]
Cadmium: I am really
sorry, this doesn't
fit our model here at S.H.H.
Cadmium: I mean, armed
security MUSHROOMS?!
Cadmium: Really?!
How do you expect
that to work?
[Waiting room
music playing]
Fun Guy Fern: Commander
Cadmium, you won't regret this!
I mean, look at
this mushroom!
Fun Guy Fern: It has
a little cop hat on!
I mean-[nervous
laughter]-I'm intimidated!
C: Look-Fun Guy Fern-you got
your start here at S.H.H., and
I respect you, but
my answer is "no".
[Notification sounds]
C: Ah, Agents Aeon and
Amethyst, come in!
Fern was... just leaving.
C: Sit down you two.
Aeon: What is
it, Commander?
C: Starting early
today, I'm afraid.
C: We have reports that
the Hawthorne Hipster is on
the outskirts of town making
some kind of huge bonfire.
C: It's raising quite
the ruckus out there.
Get on it you two!
Amethyst: Sure
thing, Commander.
Amethyst: I don't get it.
Why's the Commander so
upset about a bonfire?
Amethyst: I
mean-sure-it's annoying,
but why get us involved?
Aeon: Don't you get it?
Cadmium's worried about
all the particulate matter
being given off
by the bonfire.
Aeon: You know,
particulate matter?
It's a mixture of tiny
solid particles and
liquid droplets found
in the atmosphere.
Amethyst: It can also be known
as "particle pollution."
Amethyst: So little particles
get in the air, so what?
Aeon: Well, sometimes the
particles are just soil or dust,
but other times
organic chemicals, and
metals can become airborne.
Amethyst: Consider
this-the Hawthorne Hipster is
burning SOMETHING out there.
Amethyst: When she lights
the fire, smoke is given off.
Amethyst: That smoke will
contain tiny particles of
whatever chemicals
were in her fire.
Amethyst: [suspenseful
music] So if the chemical is
highly toxic...
Aeon:...Then it's
getting into the air.
Amethyst: Then we
better get on it!
Let's go!
[action music]
Amethyst: So how do all these
particles get in the air anyway?
Aeon: Well, human activities
like construction, mining,
processing metals or stones, or
combustion can
release particles.
Amethyst: Eh-combustion,
like bonfires...or burning
fuel to make
your car run-no?
Aeon: Yes-burning fossil
fuels will release
particles in the air.
Aeon: That's why the
agency gives us these cars
that run on kale.
It's not just human
activity though.
Aeon: Pollen, sea salt,
or dust can be blown around
from just the wind.
Aeon: Or wildfires and
volcanic activity can release
massive amounts of
particles in the air naturally.
Amethyst: [gasp]
Volcanic activity!
Like that time with the giant
chicken-in the theme song!
Aeon: Yeah, they never
show the coolest parts
from the theme song...
[action music]
Hipster: Over-produced,
big record label garbage!
Amethyst: Hey!
Hawthorn Hipster!
Knock it off!
Aeon: By the authority
given to us by S.H.H.
we order you to
cease and desist.
Aeon: You are being a MAJOR
source of pollution right now.
H: Really?
How is this any worse than
the noise pollution caused by
Tailyn Rift and her
poppy, mainstream sound?
H: You should
be thanking me.
Amethyst: Well, actually,
we're more concerned with all
the particulate matter
you're releasing into the air.
Amethyst: Those albums are
covered in plastic, and
all the chemicals in them
and the wood are thrown into
the air through that smoke.
H: So?
I'm sending Tailyn Rift's
terrible music into the sky
where it can't
hurt anyone anymore.
Aeon: See, that's where
you're wrong, Hipster.
Aeon: All those chemicals
going into the air could make
people way more ill than
country/pop fusion music.
Aeon: Depending on the
kind of particulate matter and
the level of exposure,
people who breathe in this
smoke could have exaggerated
respiratory symptoms, like
coughing or difficult breathing,
Aeon: aggravated asthma,
decreased lung functions,
irregular heartbeat,
nonfatal heart attacks, or
premature death if that person
has heart or lung disease.
H: Clearly, you've never
heard these songs...
Amethyst: And this fire
is particularly bad
because of the plastic.
Amethyst: Some particles
are called primary particles.
This matter is directly
released from the source.
Amethyst: This could
include dust or ash that's
coming from this fire.
Aeon: What we're more
concerned with right now are
the secondary particles
from your fire.
Aeon: Those chemicals in
the plastic are forming
secondary particles.
Aeon: These are particles
that form from chemical
reactions in
the atmosphere.
Aeon: Secondary particles
are the majority of
particulate matter in
the US and are commonly
released by power plants
and automobiles, and
YOU, Hawthorn Hipster.
H: You still don't
get it, do you?!
H: I am burdened with
a glorious purpose!
I am freeing us from
corporate trends!
Amethyst: Eh-she's
not getting it.
Aeon: Nope, we're going to
need one of those
blank backgrounds for
educational things to happen on.
Amethyst: Oh, goody!
I love those!
Yep, fly it in.
H: This place reminds
me of my soul.
Amethyst: Wait-are
you hipster or emo?
You've got to keep your
writing consistent.
Aeon: Ok you two, look.
This is a human hair.
Aeon: To us, they seem
very thin, but by
particulate matter
scale, it's pretty big.
Aeon: One human hair is about
50-70 micrometers in diameter.
Aeon: Here's a little
piece of particulate matter.
This could represent
dust or pollen.
Aeon: It's about 10
micrometers in diameter.
That's pretty tiny.
H: Dusty Pollen?
They sold out after
their first album.
Aeon: You're going to have a
very rich career as a barista.
Amethyst: So if that
particle is only about
10 micrometers in diameter,
that means we could stretch
five of them across
one human hair.
Aeon: Exactly, now check
this particle out.
H: Yeah, I can't
see that at all.
Aeon: It is pretty
hard to see.
Aeon: This kind of particulate
matter represents metals,
organic compounds, or particles formed from combustion.
Aeon: Like the chemicals coming
out of your burning plastic.
Amethyst: So how many
micrometers is that one?
Aeon: This is only 2.5
micrometers in diameter.
Aeon: That's so small that
four of them could fit across
the diameter of one of
our 10 micrometer particles.
H: Well, if these
particles are so tiny,
why would they cause
health problems?
H: Shouldn't they just slip
right through our bodies?
Aeon: You might think that,
but the particles ranging from
2.5 to 10 micrometers
are the most dangerous
types of particle pollution.
Aeon: In fact, particles that
are 2.5 to 10 micrometers in
diameter are what particulate
pollution is defined as.
Amethyst: I would guess that's
because the 10 micrometer
particles-like pollen-are
small enough to get in
your lungs and
aggravate allergies.
Aeon: Yep, and the
smallest particles are
the most dangerous, because
they're small enough to
get into your blood vessels.
Aeon: That's when some
major concerns can happen.
H: Hey, why's it
foggy in here?
H: Fog is SO mainstream!
Amethyst: [Sighs] So-particulate
pollution is not just a health
concern; it also contributes
to reduced visibility and haze.
H: What's that thing?
Aeon: That's a carbon
monoxide molecule.
Aeon: It's an incredibly
tiny little molecule that
can cause big problems.
Amethyst: When you burn
plastics, fossil fuels, wood,
run a car, or smoke tobacco,
you produce carbon monoxide.
H: Well it sounds like it's
already everywhere, sell out!
Aeon: It is!
Carbon monoxide is most
commonly found in car exhausts,
but it can also be found
in homes with gas furnaces,
chimneys, or
malfunctioning appliances.
Amethyst: The bigger
problem is what
carbon monoxide
does in your body.
Amethyst: Since carbon
monoxide is so small,
it can get in your blood.
Amethyst: Carbon monoxide
happens to attach well
to your red blood cells.
Amethyst: This converts
that chemical that carries
oxygen in your blood,
hemoglobin, and converts it into
a chemical called
carboxyhemoglobin.
H: I was listening to
hemoglobin back when
it was just globin.
Amethyst: You-you-HAVE to be
making this stuff up, right?
Aero: Without hemoglobin
to carry oxygen to your body,
you may experience
headaches, dizziness,
fatigue, chest pain,
difficulty breathing,
memory loss, or flu-like
symptoms in the short term.
Aero: However, if you are
exposed to too much of it,
you could develop heart
disease, damage your
nervous system, go into
a coma, or even die!
H: ...Ok, I have to admit,
that's kind of scary.
H: I'll make sure my
fire doesn't release
any carbon monoxide.
Amethyst: That's the thing,
since carbon monoxide is
colorless and
odorless-you won't
even notice it's around.
H: [alarmed] W-What?!
B-b-but how can I avoid it?!
Amethyst: Well, to start-[car
engine sound]-make sure to
never leave your car running in your garage with the door shut.
Amethyst: The carbon
monoxide could build up.
Aero: Also, make sure to get
your exhaust system regularly
checked to prevent
carbon monoxide leaks.
Mechanic: Hey, so your
suspension looks to have
leaked brake fluid all over
the internal drive shaft
which has just completely
corroded the flux capacitor.
Mechanic: That's going to
run you about $35,000.
Amethyst: Well, that sounds
like an honest assessment.
Is this enough?!
Aero: Securing your
house is important too.
Aero: Never use portable
flameless heaters in the
house or burn anything in
an area that isn't vented.
Aero: You can also install
a carbon monoxide detector in
your house to warn
you of unsafe levels.
Aero: Remember, it's just
like a smoke alarm and needs to
have its batteries
replaced regularly.
Amethyst: You could also
make sure your fireplace is
well-vented and clean.
Chimney sweep:
Evening guv'nah.
Chimney sweep: You haven't
seen a practically perfect lady
come through here, have you?
Amethyst: Not without
violating a copyright!
CS: Cheers!
[music plays]
Aero: It' not just
carbon monoxide, either.
Aero: Burnings can also
release nitrogen oxides.
Aero: These chemicals can
come in contact with rain and
become acid rain.
Aero: Acid rain can change
the chemistry of our
environment and
affect our health.
Amethyst: Or you could be
releasing sulfur dioxide.
Amethyst: It smells
AWFUL, and it makes you
feel like you're suffocating.
Amethyst: Not only is it
gross, it can burn your
skin and eyes or cause
respiratory irritation.
Aero: And who knows
what other effects
the chemicals you're
releasing could have?!
Cop: All right!
Time to put this fire out!
-[sniff sniff]-
woah-what's in the air
here-I suddenly feel like-
Cop: [starts singing]
-Oh-I'm fifteen!
-and it's really hard-and
dad's on a tractor-and
the boy doesn't like me-
Cop: -why won't he go
to the dance with me!?
-I'm fifteen!
-uh-fifteen's-uh-tough!
Hipster: Aaah! OK!
I'll put it out!
Amethyst: I'm glad we
could solve this situation
without tempers [brief
pause]-flaring-
Aero: [unimpressed sigh] I
don't get paid enough for this.
Amethyst: Hey! Come on!
We need to work on
our-witty agent banter!
Amethyst: Oh gosh-hey, we need
to make a quick stop before
we get back to headquarters.
Aero: I keep telling
you-that's not a farmer's
market-it's a pet store.
Amethyst: No, no no-n-not
that-I forgot my ID.
We have to go
to my apartment.
Aero: Y-Y-Y-YOUR
apartment-as in
[with outrage]
Y-O-U-R-YOUR-apartment?
Amethyst: R-Relax!
It'll be fine.
Aero: Look-I just
remember the holiday
party a few years back!
Amethyst: I took
care of the badger.
You'll see,
it's no problem!
Aeon: Well-this place
is a reality show
waiting to happen...
Amethyst: Hey-I don't
judge you for that perm.
1993 called, it wants
its hairstyle back!
[cutesy voice]
Hello, Sprinkles.
Hello, Mr. Giggles.
[cutesy voice] Hello,
Cuddie-fluffle-wuffle.
Dr. Cutesyhugs, holder of
PhD in cuddles.
[cutesy voice]
Hello, Stripes the Tiger.
Aeon: Ok, Stripes is
definitely a raccoon.
Amethyst: Nah-you're a raccoon.
Aeon: Just hurry up
and find your ID.
Amethyst: Don't worry,
it's right here underneath
my dinner-from Tuesday.
Aeon: -It's-FRIDAY!!!
Amethyst: Oh,
and-YOU'VE-never had leftovers?!
Aeon: We SERIOUSLY have to
deal with the particulate matter
in here-this place is
an absolute biohazard!
Amethyst: What do you mean?
I'm not burning
anything in here.
How is there
particulate matter?
Aeon: Not all particulate
matter is chemical.
Aeon: A huge amount of
particulate matter comes from
a biological,
or living, origin.
Amethyst: Oh,
sure, like pollen?
I know all about that!
Aeon: [surprised] You do?
Amethyst: Yea, my
allergies are crazy bad.
Pollen is the male
reproductive cell in a plant.
Amethyst: Many trees release
billions of pollen grains to
fertilize other
trees and form seeds.
Amethyst: Pollen can be
carried by insects or other
pollinating animals
between plants.
Amethyst: This pollen is usually
used by flowering plants, and
doesn't create a lot
of problems for humans.
Amethyst: Other plants use
the wind to carry pollen,
THOSE plants
are the problem.
Amethyst: This pollen
can aggravate symptoms of
hay fever or asthma.
Amethyst: This impacts about 25% of the population in the U.S.
Amethyst: [sniffles]-Uh
oh...ah ah ahhhhhhchoo!
Aeon: Let me help out here.
Aeon: Pollen counts in the
air are highest in the early
morning hours
between 5 and 10 AM.
Aeon: Dry, windy, hot days are
ideal times for pollen to be
released, so watch out if
you know this impacts you.
Amethyst: [sniffling]
Look you see?
That's why I don't have
ANY plants in here.
Aeon: Ok, but you
still have some MAJOR
particulate
matter sources.
Aeon: Haven't you noticed
all those green and white
fuzzy patches all
over your apartment?
Amethyst: Oh, you mean the
snuggle patches on my walls?
Aeon: [with outrage] Those
AREN'T snuggle patches!
They're MOLD!
FUNGUS!
BAD!
Amethyst: Aw come on...
How can fungus
hurt anybody?
The word "fun"
is right in it!
Aeon: [with
disbelief] Oh gosh-ok!
Similar to plants-fungi have
reproductive cells
called spores.
Aeon: Like pollen, fungal
spores can be carried by
the wind and insects
or even in water.
Aeon: In fact, fungal
spores are more common in
the atmosphere than pollen.
Amethyst: But can spores cause
the same problems as pollen?
Aeon: They sure can.
Spores can cause allergen
side-effects like
sneezing, runny nose,
mucous production,
Aeon: cough, congestion,
earache, headache, wheezing,
asthma, or other
illnesses like asthma.
Amethyst: Oh great...
Aeon: I'm not done yet.
Aeon: The worst bit is that
fungi release chemicals called
mycotoxins when they
break down their food.
Aeon: These mycotoxins
can also get on spores
before they enter your body.
Aeon: In your body, mycotoxins
can cause infections.
Some of these mycotoxins
can cause cancer,
asthma-like illnesses,
and some are even fatal.
Amethyst: Ah!
Ok, get rid of the mold,
get rid of the mold!
Aeon: I'm not done yet.
We still need to
talk about THOSE!
Amethyst: AUGH!
Not my preciouses!
Aeon: Not just the cats.
Aeon: It's also the nasty
dust all over this place.
Your dirty clothes,
Aeon: these sheets you
probably haven't changed
since YOLO was a thing.
Amethyst: What about them?
Aeon: They're all
encouraging dust mites.
Amethyst: Dust-mites-?
Aeon: Here-look!
Dust mites!
Aeon: These little guys
are microscopic arachnids,
the relatives of
spiders and ticks.
Aeon: They feed on the
flakes of skin that
people and animals
shed ALL-THE-TIME!
Amethyst:
Gross-get a life, guys!
Aeon: Well-we do need
them-otherwise that stuff
would just sit around and
we'd be wading in dead skin-
Aeon: but we don't need
to provide them with an
International House of
Detritus-like you have.
Aeon: The remains dust
mites leave behind are
the main cause of dust
allergies in people,
Aeon: And they're
found EVERYWHERE.
Aeon: Mattresses, pillows,
bed linens, carpets,
draperies, upholstered
furniture, even stuffed toys.
Amethyst: Ok, fungal
spores and dust mites.
Amethyst: This place is
literally filled with
particulate matter.
How can I fix it?
Aeon: Well-for the mites
we need to WASH-YOUR-STUFF!
Aeon: You should be washing your
sheets weekly in water above
130 degrees (F°) to
take care of the mites.
Aeon: Also, make sure that all
of this dust is cleaned-vacuum
regularly to keep the dust
and cat hair from collecting.
Aeon: For the spores, make
sure you have all the areas of
your apartment well
ventilated to prevent moisture.
Aeon: I would also suggest
that you maybe start wrapping
your food and-like use the FRIDGE-instead of the floor-!
Aeon: However, we already
have mold growing on the walls.
Aeon: We need to clean up
this stuff with BLEACH-like
5 or 6 of these!
Aeon: Much better.
[Action music playing]
Amethyst: We better get back
to headquarters quick.
The Commander's
going to be steamed.
Amethyst: Hey, Steve.
Aeon: Wait-Amethyst!
-This isn't!
-Hey!
-Wait!
Amethyst: [laughing]-So
then, we got her to
stop burning the records
Amethyst: because this guy
was singing songs about how
being a 15 year-old-girl
was so hard!
Aeon: Hey-Amethyst-don't
you notice something weird
going on
here-[startled]-AAH!!
Aeon: What's with
the commander?!
Amethyst: [whispering]
Look-he's sensitive about that
new hairpiece-be nice!
Aeon: That's-NOT-a wig!
Amethyst: Ok, now you're
just trying to oversell it.
Aeon: No-look!
-It's-uh-It's a MUSHROOM!
Amethyst: [gasp!] You're right!
-[with surprise]-
Oh my gosh!
Amethyst: This green
haze must be spores!
They're everywhere!
Aeon: Ok-what are
we going to do?
Amethyst: Looks
like the spores are
coming out of the vents.
Amethyst: I'll go look for
the source, you take care of
the commander's office.
[Suspense-Action music]
Aeon: Deal.
Aeon: Woah-these must
be military grade.
Amethyst: [suspense-action
music]-[grunting] Almost there.
[Gasping for air]-
Must-keep-going.
[action music]
Aeon: Let' do this.
Fun Guy: Ignore me will he?
-Scoff at my ideas?
Fun Guy: [Giggling] Well,
frankly, Commander Cadmium,
I find you to be
a-[brief pause]-
SPORE-[evil laughter]-muah hahahahahahahaha!!!!!
Amethyst: How do I get out of this vent?
-whoa-whoa-whoaaah! -
heh-hah! -Smooth...
Amethyst: The gig's
up Fun Guy Fern...OHH!
-Ohh-FUN-GUY-FERN-ohh-like
fungi!
Amethyst: Oh my gosh, that
makes so much sense now.
F: It's too late Amethyst,
I've already taken over!
[secret agent music]
Aero: You were saying?
Cadmium: For protecting
the Super Hidden Humans from
the dangers of particulate
matter-both chemical AND
organic-I promote you
two to level 8 agents.
Cadmium: [whispers] Now you
get to know-Phil's still alive.
Hairy Agent: Graaaaaar!
[Action music playing]